poor new screenwriter who's just
finished their first screenplay what do
they do with it alright so you're saying
like you write a screenplay you don't
know nothing about nothing right you
just wrote something okay
internet internet this is this is the
the connectivity of the world is in
everybody's palm cuz it's on the phone
there are contests and websites there's
all kinds of stuff where you can submit
a screenplay and get some kind of
feedback on it like if you're waiting
for universal to show up and grab up
your scripts you'll be waiting a very
long time however get it out there find
it let people say no to you like don't
be so precious about it just get it out
there because if you do that and you put
it in the hands of different places and
different websites like egg tip comm
like where you can just like post your
script there for producers to look at if
they dig your logline
you're gonna learn stuff and you're
gonna understand like what's working if
nobody clicks on your script you got
work to do if people do click on your
script you're gonna find out what the
deal is from them you know especially
Mouse weird cuz the whole Writers Guild
thing that's going on so I mean I guess
you could submit to agents I don't know
if agent can touch anything now I don't
know what it is
but even before that the that whole
process is hard because agents are
agencies are also companies now they
have bottom line they got a have
certain amount of money coming in and
they are dependent on higher-level
clients that are known on the studio
level doesn't mean you can't get an
agent but a lot of times these contests
film festivals have screenwriting
contests in them you know the Sundance
lab is a place that you can submit your
script to a lot of agents our judges at
that thing so you send your scripts
something agent might see it and be like
cool now you skipped a bunch of steps
which is a lot better than you know
complaining on Twitter about nobody
reading your script
you know it's work you got to get out
and do a little work you know nothing's
just gonna land in your lap no body is
going to land in your lap everybody's
out there trying to get their stuff done
too you know doesn't mean can't work
together with people but you show me
you're willing to do something get it
out there move it around what about what
you said earlier is like let people say
no to you yeah is that like a skill yeah
Jay kidding everybody hates no now I'm
you know back in the day no was normal
yeah they know has changed
you